Michael how are you do are you doing
Dave better than I deserve
how can I help well here recently about
a year ago I'd gone into a franchise and
things aren't going so well now and I
still have a full-time job my wife works
and I'm looking at what the best resolve
if I want to get out of this is
obviously I personally guaranteed
everything so there's a chapter 13 or
debt relief you know going with their
attorney look like an OIC and offer and
compromise or what is it on best route
to do this oh I see you got back taxes
well I I actually all on the SBA loan I
ran up some credit-card debt
oh I see oh it's only apply to IRS taxes
oh really yeah the FDA loans also know
you could mean you can try to compromise
with anybody on any loan but the OIC is
a process for back taxes okay so how
much did you borrow to buy this and what
did you buy I bought a service franchise
and I owe 138 on the SBA I wrestle about
30 grand on a credit card 20 grand on a
HELOC and I owe 20 25 thousand on
payroll taxes and what's wrong with the
business it's just not cash flow in
itself so like I said I work full time
and another job what does they hate what
is the nature of the business what kind
of service business like junk removal
okay and why are you why is there not
enough junk being removed just just a
lot of overhead compared to what I'm
bringing in so okay when you were
looking at this you didn't buy it to do
what it's doing you thought it was going
to do more or did you miss I'm not sure
where these higher are that income lower
the expenses got higher than what you
thought yeah then what they told you
okay so you paid a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars for a franchise to do
junk removal that's correct okay how
much equities in your home referee says
sixty-five seventy thousand above the
SBA loan or to cover the SBA loan oh I
thought you just made equity in the
house is that what you said I'm sorry I
thought the you SBA loan took a second
on your house didn't they yeah I had the
personal guarantee these loans you have
a second on your house with the SBA do
you not I have a second I'm just where I
pull cash for cash flow oh you don't
have the SBA didn't take a lien on your
house they didn't I had to personally
guarantee it so they do have a lien on
it
that's a call it's called on the
mortgage okay that's called a second
mortgage and so yeah so okay you have
you have three mortgages counting the
SBA on your home right yes is there
selling your home clear all of them no
ouch yeah
what would it clear what would be left
standing um I would still see what's
your first one any first mortgage at 190
okay and 130 on the SBA and the second
mortgage or the other mortgage that
you've got that you took out for cash
flows what 21,000 okay
what's the house worth 270 so your 80 in
the hole okay yeah so you're doing the
top line as much as you thought you
would do your gross sales are as much as
you thought they were going to be yeah
they were actually up for a while we
slowed down here this is number checks I
mean your projections when you bought
this stupid thing you're making
projections on your sales yes
it's the expenses that are killing you
correct by double I mean they must be
double yeah yeah some of them are yes
have you made a profit at all
mmm no no I haven't taken any money out
of the business and basically was just
trying to pay from the business yeah
okay so your revenues aren't even
covering your expenses is what you're
saying
I'm written even basically what I'm
doing but so going into the slope here
is what I know I'm not going to break
even so trying to figure out what my
best route is I mean do I head it off or
do I just actually pull for my weight
like a franchisor and look for a buyer
it I'm in the process of trying to sell
it now yeah obviously the franchisee or
a franchisor any help
oh yeah somewhat yep okay because if you
can get a hundred out of this thing and
sell your house you could you can walk
away mm-hmm and I don't know what the
homestead exemption is in Indiana but in
most states you're not going to get to
keep as much you know your your home is
going to be going for all this equity
you're not going to get to if you want
to get rid of these loans that have a
lien on your house the only way to do
it's get rid of your house in bankruptcy
or out and so you've lost your house if
you do this if you don't keep this
business running and make it profitable
and the only question is how much debts
left over after you've lost your house
and if you've if you can sell the house
and sell the business you probably can
come out of this pretty close and and
that's going to be your that's going to
be our number one target is doing all of
that but it's not it's
yeah it might be a chapter 13 might be a
chapter 11 but to talk to your attorney
about that if that's what you're facing
but I would use bankruptcy as my
absolute last resort instead I would try
to get some cash on the table from some
buyers and make deals with some of these
lenders and see if I can't clear it and
get a fresh start at zero